turning to the economy Americans saw a
big chunk of their stock market savings
disappear yesterday over fears of an
economic recession the Dow Jones
Industrial Average fell 800 points
that's the biggest drop of the year more
than three percent
this morning's market futures predict
another decline at the open today Don
Dahler is at the New York Stock Exchange
Don what is it that's making investors
so nervous hey good morning well it's
something called an inverted yield curve
and the bond market hasn't seen this
since before the Great Recession in 2007
it basically indicates that investors
are losing confidence in the economy and
while that might sound scary it might
also present some opportunities for
consumers the closing bell on Wall
Street was a sour note for investors
Wednesday as a key indicator in the bond
market signaled the recession could be
on its way
CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger what investors are telling
us is that they're quite uncertain about
the future they're worried about what
stocks are gonna do in the future
they're worried about what the economy
is gonna do in the future for the first
time in more than a decade the yield for
the ten-year bond dipped below the yield
for the two-year bond that means
investors are more willing to bet on the
short term economy than the outlook for
the long term so an inverted yield curve
can be a signal that things will slow
down in the future and has often been a
sign of recession president Trump has
been quick to blame the Federal
Reserve's actions on interest rates
tweeting crazy inverted yield curve we
should easily be reaping big rewards and
gains but the Fed is holding us back but
analysts point to other factors as well
including the u.s. trade war with China
and economic slowdowns in Germany France
and the UK now the question is how
quickly will the Federal Reserve Act to
stave off further slowdowns or when the
president and the administration will
sit down with China and remove this
cloud of uncertainty now a recession is
by no means inevitable and if one does
happen it could take 18 to 24 months to
develop and there is a silver lining in
this because of this
instability the cost of long-term
borrowing is going down which might mean
it's a good time to buy a house or
Anthony that new Corvette how did you
know done I was in the market for a new
Corvette why thanks who isn't a good
point